Scott Pilgrim I love this movie I think
there are three different elements Nico
do you know what they are I think I see
it
thanks to Ray Khan for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get 15% off your very own set of
earbuds hey what's up welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react today we've got some
pretty sweet looking shots we got some
historical landmarks of visual effects
we're gonna take a look at and a couple
goofs as well seaton watch the video
that's what I was gonna say Scott
Pilgrim Scott Pilgrim has been so highly
requested like forever I love this movie
so people remember that there are
effects in this movie but that's because
it's so like cartoony and comic style
for instance this scene right here has a
moment where he just like takes him and
throws him across the parking lot and
into like a castle hey I'm talking to
you there's Captain America right there
that's not Captain America no it's the
Human Torch
to quote a friend of mine it's
clobbering time
[Applause]
he just throws him and any cheers feels
like yeah dude look at that sick so
that's a shot that's hot right there
very strange and cool I think there's a
few things going on here I think there
are three different elements Nico do you
know what they are yeah I would say you
got a stud man a digital double and then
michael cera in the foreground all being
stitched together what the magic of
computers perfect that was exactly what
I was gonna say there's obviously some
sort of stunt guy like getting into
position and then falling down through
that thing let's see if we can see when
it goes from the stunt guy to see gwg
right there
did you see how the rotation kind of
went in kisses yeah there's a transition
to michael cera definitely like there's
a stunt and there's Michael Cera and
then somebody's like I gotta fix
I gotta connect the two was CG like in
the movie 1917 yeah exactly
way more janky so okay what frame
exactly did he go from the did you
double back to me yeah that's true
michael cera does look a lot like you
there are so many visual effects in this
movie too but the cool thing about them
is that there's not a lot of
computer-generated stuff most of the
time there's a lot of like distortion
effects and like text on-screen anime
lines look at those anime lines there so
that fire there how do you think they're
getting that how are they making that
fire sling gems huh I think it's slim
jims so there's something I really like
here it's not just CG elements like you
know energy looking elements on top of
the video take a look at the guitar and
see how the guitar smears yes I was I
was noticing the same thing so that's
really cool because if you've ever tried
doing visual effects like you may have a
cool laser a factor energy effect and
you drop on your footage it doesn't feel
like it's part of the footage and things
like having distortion where the footage
itself is being distorted is a great way
to like have things like feel like
they're impacting that world because
it'd be so easy for this like energy
wave just to feel like it's literally a
light layer put on top of the film but
in this case it's smearing the guitar
it's giving the impression of like wind
and things like that one other thing
that I really appreciate is that they
are doing a lot of practical lighting on
set to match these effects that are
being added in post like their timing
and syncing lighting effects on set to
later on match the effects that are put
into the footage months down the line
and that takes planning that takes a
vision that's what I think signifies a
good director who cares about their
their work versus the other people are
just phoning it in and they show up on
the day and they just yeah put a camera
there film the actors done let me talk
about how like this you know it's like
anime in real life right and we've done
our fair share of live-action anime
videos so like what does it mean to have
live-action anime well obviously there's
things like having text on screen and
anime lines but when you look at anime
it's it's it's drawing from the fact
that well no pun intended they're
drawings you don't have a lot of frames
in your budget you have to basically
sell motion and sell a story with the
minimal amount of drawings possible so
you do things like lines to convey
motion and they use just normal zooms
and pans to convey motion and that's
where the whole like anime blurred
background comes into play because you
want to show somebody flying at you but
you only have one frame that you can
have something in a pose and then you
just paint one picture of lines and then
you just zip it back and forth real
quick and so that lets you have motion
and kinetic energy while still only
having like
one or two drawings maybe their mouth is
moving or whatever you're swapping that
out they emulate that here when they
have Scott Pilgrim flying forward with a
punch like their bodies are relatively
still but the position of their bodies
are moving there's a great new thing
it's a super cool movie I really watched
it pretty recently as well and it's
awesome and no one went to see it in
theaters so in one of our last videos
Clint was like I got a jacked up clip
for you and I was like guys that octopus
is really jacked up and if you have
any other jacked up visual effects clips
let us know in the comments below and
you did you followed through on it and I
went through those comments and someone
wanted us to check out this scene from
looper I love this movie there's some
really good stuff in looper
this character is noticing physical
changes in his body that are happening
in a past version of himself and they're
appearing on him in real-time and his
nose is gone there's something so like
visceral about seeing a chopped-off nose
this is so jacked up this chop his leg
off his legs disappeared while he was
walking yeah super and like he collapsed
through where his legs should have been
yeah I wonder how they did the legs
disappear yeah his legs obviously
disappear within his pants and he
collapses so it's something that
possibly could have just been done
practically but it was so well done I'm
not sure how they did it I think I see
it I think he actually has a leg and I
think he falls down and the moaning
starts falling down they painted out and
they replace it with a cloth simulation
they're basically just doing what we did
in our short paper cuts we do an effect
where I hit them and when I hit the
person the person turns into a flat
piece of paper it's torn in half and
flutters away it's a real person that
then he gets erased in the shot and gets
replaced in the cloth simulation but in
the case of paper cuts it acts like
paper route then you know the legs of
pants Nico's hunger is that right I look
this one up you first off that car crash
and him coming out our two shots
stitched together with a stunt actor
crashes the car for real
and then they stitched that with another
shot of him coming out of the car to
transition into this and for this entire
take here it's a full-body take and they
basically just transitioned the limbs
into cloth simulations and paint out the
existing limbs okay from it like a
filming perspective it's pretty simple
there are like tracking markers on his
body that they're using for like the
animation and stuff like that they set
up some witness cameras around there to
try and get the animation as smooth as
possible that's so well done yeah what's
so well done it's it's a really simple
execution on set and the effect is
really visceral thanks for that jacked
up shots and that was pretty jacked up
jacked up movies leave them in the
comments we're reading them and I'm
happy to go through more of these
because sometimes the most jacked up
shots require the most jacked up the
effects
[Music]
so this is a movie called the abbeys and
it came after two Minotaur and aliens
and before - - ort so there is a
groundbreaking visual effects shot in
this movie and it is this like water
snake thing they called it a pseudo pod
this is a big precursor to the t1000
right here yeah yeah look at that look
at that face it's mirroring her face
right there good effects are good it
just looks weird it's look like the
practical light of like the water
reflections they're doing all over the
place to constantly like motivate the
creature
[Music]
wait why why she just tickled his brain
and licked it so I want to explain why
this is such a big deal
the only other CG character that had
ever been done before this was the
stained glass man this shot was so
groundbreaking at the time they were
uncertain if they were gonna be able to
do it at all
so James came and literally wrote this
entire scene to be removed from the
movie if it came down to it we're
looking through this liquid material
this this medium that you can actually
see through so there's a couple
different things happening one is it's
basically refracting everything behind
it and is causing the image to like
invert and like distort but you're also
seeing reflections on the surface of the
water and all of that requires imagery
to actually pass through it and that's
something that had never been done
before they weren't sure if they could
do this but there was one guy who was
like no we got this and his name was
John Knoll his name is John like John
Knoll is like one of my VFX heroes he's
like okay we need to see through the
water so he took his camera and he took
photos of the set any like every angle
possible from every light from every
camera like just kind of getting the
whole set and he actually stitched all
those images together using this program
that him and his brother invented called
Photoshop yeah that's right John Knoll
along with his brother invented
Photoshop and what John Knoll did with
taking all those photos is it gave the
rendering program something to actually
project through
the water medium itself he basically
created the standard of taking photos of
the set so that anytime you're having
visual effects you can add that stuff
back in exactly as it was on set this
would certainly be a lot easier to do
now however you wouldn't be able to do
it without the same principles they used
on set to make this film way back in the
day you still have to have those methods
and procedures involved also this is the
first example of like doing like
morphing that the digital face there
morphs between her face and Ed Harris's
face I mean just as a guess if like I
was back then and trying to keep this as
simple as possible the way you're gonna
build these CG faces is probably by
making sure there's a uniform amount of
vertices between them so that way when
you're animating in morphing between the
two shapes you can simply just take
these two vertices and everything slides
in into a new location but the
underlying structure of the face stays
identical just like everything about it
is just like by the books in the best
way just kind of blown away and in the
back of my head I'm going like James
Cameron is the best filmmaker of the
20th century he is straight up also John
Knoll if you're seeing this please
consider coming on our show we'd love to
have you that would be amazing that
would be that would be like a dream come
true if you or anyone you know knows
John Knoll let us know hey guys this
episode of VFX artists react is brought
to you by ray con earbuds my dad hit me
up because he likes to do a lot of like
hiking and walking and you know full-on
ear covering headphones that get kind of
hot and sweaty and so he's like you know
is there is there an earbud that you
recommend well dad I recommend these
guys the every day
e 25 I talked to Jake and Jake was like
Niko if you do the next integration
we'll send a box to your dad so yeah
keep an eye on the mailbox in a week cuz
I'm doing it there's a bunch of great
features that my dad will enjoy such as
a sleek design no stems and the wires
hanging out my dad loves bass the bass
response on these guys is great my dad
loves fun colors these guys come in all
sorts of colors they can be personalized
to match your personality and on top of
that my dad likes to listen to lots of
music for a long time and the battery
life on these guys last for six hours on
top that you recharge them four times
in their case so if you're looking for a
nice pair of earbuds I offer seamless
Bluetooth connection and great bass
response go to the link in the
description below or you go to buy rack
on comms left cord or crew type it into
your RL manually because I don't know
maybe you're a person who likes doing
that okay hey everybody thanks for
watching this episode of bee effects
artists react if there are any clips
that you wants to react to from movies
please leave a comment down below we'll
take the good ones we'll take the bad
ones we'll take the weird ones dude
someone mentioned to Animorphs we're
gonna have to talk about that next time
oh yeah we're gonna do Animorphs next
time if there's any kooky kids shows
that had some badly effects in it let us
know I I wish I was there for the beast
wars episode because I watched that a
lot and I had a lot of Beast Wars action
figures
and I always wanted to know how they did
it yeah you know being on this show then
you lot magically know I come here so
you guys get make me a better visual
text artist Oh